un jeu de 52 cartes soigneusement
mélangé le défi de ce jeune
suédois les mémoriser dans l'ordre en un
minimum de temps il s'appelle Marvin et
a seulement 21 ans ce génie de la
mémoire est capable d'exploits
incroyables 33 secondes et 3 cè pour
retenir un paquet entier est-ce possible
Marvin doit maintenant mettre ses
neurones en action sous l'œil des juges
pour reconstituer la suite de
[Musique]
cartes ne reste plus qu'à comparer sa
combinaison avec le paquet témoin pour
connaître le
verdict
zéro
faute c'est le genre de press
exceptionnel qui ont fait de Marvin une
star
planétaire pouvez faire mieux bien mieux
le N pas de
limite c'est toixm le CER n' pas demite
comme lui ils sont 275 à tenter de
repousser les limites du cerveau humain
en participant au championnat du monde
de la mémoire des candidats de 27 pays
jours de compé les plus jeunes que 8 ans
soz Brill
aujourd'hui vous êtes les guerriers de
l'esprit au milieu de cette
concentration de matière grise unique au
monde jo2 ans le seul candidat français
il s qualifi grâce à un bon scoreun
championnat
[Musique]
europé'huiis cent en quelques
minutes retenir des suites de milliers
de chiffres ou encore à prendre par cœur
des dizaines de paquets de cartes tu
prends du plaisir ici là depuis tu ici
oui je prends du plaisir mais aussi
beaucoup de mal de tête he parce qu'il y
a des épruves qui demandent grande
concentration et au bout d'une heure ou
2 he c'esttendu surtout que il faut
éviter de faire la moindre
erreur Joël pourra-t-il battre Marvin le
jeune prodige suédois et remporter le
premier prix un chèque de 30000
€ quels sont les secrets de ces athlètes
de
l'intelligence aussi incroyable que cela
puisse paraître vous allez découvrir que
nous possédons tous un cerveau capable
comme eux de réaliser des
[Musique]
miracles c'est à Marseille où il habite
que Joël a préparé depuis plus d'un an
les championnats du monde de la
mémoire nous le retrouvons quelques
jours avant son départ pour la Chine en
pleine
révision ce matin contrairement aux
apparence Joël ne se balade pas sur le
vieux port il s'exerce à retenir un
maximum de plaques d'immatriculation de
bateau 30 82
44 30 81
92 48 10 24 en me concentrant bien en
étant calme je pense que je dois être
capable de retenir
200 pourtant ce formateur de profession
ne possède pas un cuit hors norme
sa mémoire d'éléphant c'est par passion
qu'il l'a développé grâce à certaines
techniques apprises dans des manuels
comme
celui-ci c'est un livre que j'ai trouvé
purement par hasard et ce livre est en
effet explique bien toutes les
principales techniques de mémorisation
comment retenir un texte que le fait de
plus on app apprend plus on développe
notre capacité de mémorisation comment
il faut être tout à fait curieux hein il
do avoir une cinquantaine de livres sur
la mémoire là la la mémoire
intelligente c'est sur la base de ces
méthodes que Joë s'entraî depuis plus de
4 ans à booster ses
neurones le logiciel est là par exemple
pour mémoriser une suite de chiffres en
un temps
record l'une des techniques consiste à
isoler les chiffres par groupe de trois
chaque nombre correspond à un mot
déterminé et appris à
l'avance il suffit de remplacer chaque
groupe de chiffres par le mot
correspondant
et de s'inventer une histoire avec ses
mots un jeu d'enfant sauf qu'à 6000 km
de Marseille en Chine dans quelques
jours ce ne sont pas quelques chiffres
mais des milliers que Joël va devoir
retenir il faudra redoubler
d'imagination pour s'inventer un roman à
chaque
épreuve
nous sommes à Chengdu une ville
industrielle en plein cœur de la
Chine c'est ici dans le centre de
conférence que va se dérouler la 24e
édition de la compétition pendant 3
jours ce matin Jo a un petit peu
l'impression de retourner sur les bans
de l'école en découvrant ses
concurrentsexamen d'utant plus qu'il y a
180 chinois et donc beaucoup d'enfants
c'est comme une rentrée des
classes l'équipe chinoise est la plus
redoutée des adolescents mais aussi des
bambins surdoués d'une dizaine d'années
encadrés par des coachs aux méthodes
révolutionnair il y a 2 ans je l'ai
repéré car il est vraiment
passionné un mois seulement après avoir
appris la méthode de mémorisation il a
réussi à réciter très couramment deux
poèmes de
Mao des poèmes particulièrement
difficiles à
mémoriser je trouve ça très amusant
d'être là je rencontre des gens
intéressants les entraînements c'est
sympa mais la compétition c'est mieux
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de
participer à ce
championnat allez bon
courage au programme du jour une épreuve
qui va demander une concentration
surhumaine à
Joël au jeunes champion chinois mais
également à Marvin le gé suédois qui se
met toujours debout pour se
concentrer par il s'agit de retenir par
cœur et dans l'ordre cette liste de
chiffres distribué par les juges une
torture pour le cerveau imaginé par cet
homme Tony
Buzan auteur de plusieurs ouvrages sur
la mémoire c'est Lui qui a créé cette
compétition ça c'est une des épreuves de
nombre
là il y a 5000
chiffres les gens se disent c'est
impossible personne ne peut retenir tout
ça vérité le cerveau humain peut les
mémoriser ils n'ont qu'une heure pour
mémoriser les 5000
chiffres une opération faile pours
ordinurs mais très éprouvante pour
leerau technique pour se concentrer mais
pour tous le même but regrouper les
chiffres les transformer en mots et se
fabriquer sa petite histoire
[Musique]
ensuite les candidats ont un quart
d'heure pour restituer les chiffres dans
un
tableau Marvin est l'un des premiers à
sortir attendu par ses parents qui l'ont
accompagné en Chine pour cette épreuve
le fils prodige s'est inventé un
scénario digne d'une production
hollywoodienne une
Bane un
Pokémon et comment on dit déjà un
paraplu ça fait un scénario le Pokémon
tient parapluie il des
banesm
est chiffre et son scénario ressemblait
plus à une série télé bien française du
vin qui se renverse sur un costume et
qui tombe également sous la nuque de
Jacques Delor Jacques Delor c'était pour
moi le numéro 97 par exemple on a
intérêt à prendre de l'aspirine c'est
une épreuve redoutable redoutable dans
le sens où il faut surtout surtout ne
pas se tromper de chiffres dans la
reconstitution l'épreuve est remportée
par Marvin
valonius à l'annonce des résultats
[Applaudissements]
l' il a mémorisé par cur
chiffr un nouveau record du monde qui
fait la fierté de toute la
famille maintenant il est premier au
classement vous êtes F de lui on est
vraiment très fier de lui vraiment très
Fierz il est norm la
maisair joue au carartes avec ses frères
et sœurs il sait ce qu'ils ont dans les
mains c'est amusant il connaît toujours
d'avance ce qu'ils vont
jouer en plus des méthodes apprises dans
les livres cet étudiant en médecine a un
petit secret bien à lui pour rester au
top niveau vous allez où
maintenant au gymnase pour faire de
l'exercice
physique avant et après chaque épreuve
direction la salle de sport pour faire
travailler ses muscles
selon lui c'est un moyen infaillible de
booster l'oxygénation du cerveau et donc
de doper ses
[Musique]
neurones moi je mange un minimum parce
que la digestion ça pompe de l'oxygène
au
cerveau et surtout je m'entraîne juste
avant les épreuves ou alors je vais
faire un footing parce que ça te fait
une décharge d'énergie dans le cerveau
si tu cours juste avant
c'est une mise en condition bien
différente que Joë a choisi pour les
épreuves suivantes classé dans les
derniers après cette première journée il
a décidé de se
requinquer vous mettez ce doigt ici et
l'autre là en découvrant les spécialités
locales avec un candidat danois il va
tenter de cuisiner une jeune concurrente
chinoise et son
entraîneur of
avecous de percer le secretlèes chinois
de la mémoire si on veut les
concurrencer il faut bien qu'on perce
les secret si demain on a une
progression très nette c'est
soja si Joë ne trouve pas rapidement la
solution cette épopée chinoise risque de
lui rester sur
[Musique]
l'estomac pendant 3 jours le français et
ses concurrents enchaînent une dizaine
d'épreuves jusqu'au bout de leur force
et malgré tous les effort du Marseillais
difficile de rivaliser avec les jeunes
chinois et le champion
[Musique]
suédois si bien qu'à l' du dernier jour
il n'y a pas que le ciel de chengu qui
soit
embrumé le cerveau de Joël aussi
et pourtant pour cette épreuve ce n'est
plus un mais 40 jeux de cartes que les
candidats doivent mémoriser en seulement
une
heure l'idéal est d'arriver à retenir 10
paquets au moins dans
l' Joë est dans les derniers au
classement Marvin est toujours en tête
mais talonné de près par ce champion
américain Alex mulen entre eux tout va
se jouer maintenant il vous reste une
minute après vérification par les juges
c'est l'Américain qui l'emporte au
finish grâce à un incroyable exploit il
a retenu par cœur et dans l'ordre 28
paquets soit 1456
cartes lui s trompé dès le premier
paquet
est ouf la fin l'après-midi c'était
c'était long et ça demandait encore une
fois beaucoup de concentration et là
c'était fatigant sur les
cartes Joë termine avantdernier du
championnat c'est l'Américain qui
remporte le chèque de 30000 € et le
titre de maître de la mémoire Marvin
termine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2e les Chinois euortent le premier prix
prochain rendez-vous pour ces génies de
la mémoire en décembre prochain à
Singapour